almost no other predator on the planet
inspires as much terror
and curiosity
as the python
[Music]
one of the world's longest snakes is a
python
the reticulated python of southeast asia
usually grows around 16 feet long
however the current record holder for
the longest reticulated python measured
at 25 feet
python's long bodies help the reptiles
killed by way of constriction
they wrap their bodies around prey and
every time the prey exhales
the python squeezes more tightly
this disrupts the prey's respiration and
blood flow inevitably leading to its
death
pythons have legs
called spurs these two limbs appear as
small bumps on the sides of a python's
pelvis
while too small for locomotive function
the spurs and pelvis are remnants of
python's evolution from lizards
this evolution occurred around 100
million years ago
one possible early ancestor of pythons
called the tetrapadophus was a fusion of
lizard and snake-like features and had
hind legs
interestingly scientists found that
pythons have retained the genetic
mutation for growing limbs
this means pythons may be capable of
having fully functional legs once again
[Music]
pythons do not unhinge their jaws when
they eat
contrary to popular belief pythons
cannot unhinge their jaws
rather their jaws rest on a multi-hinged
joint that provides for incredible
flexibility and enables the snakes to
devour large prey
flexibility is also aided by python's
lower right and left jaw bones
unlike mammals which have one solid
lower jaw bone python's lower jaws are
made of two bones linked by an elastic
ligament
this allows the bones to stretch more
widely to help swallow prey at least two
to three times wider than the snake's
head
python skulls can walk over prey
pythons have six rows of teeth in their
skulls
two in their lower jaws two in their
upper jaws and two more in the roof of
their mouth
through a phenomenon called cranial
kinesis or pterygoid walk each of these
rows can be moved independently which
allows snakes to drag prey into their
throats without the use of front limbs
python teeth also help this process
they are extremely sharp and curved
backwards
perfect for catching and clinging onto
prey
some pythons have become invasive
species
while native to the tropics of africa
asia and australia
several python species have been
transported to the united states by way
of pet trafficking
florida's everglades national park in
particular is home to tens of thousands
of invasive burmese pythons
poor care neglect and accidents have
caused many pythons originally taken in
as pets to kill native wildlife other
pets and even children
but when left alone in their natural
habitat pythons are generally docile
pythons are some of nature's most
incredible predators
their long bodies
constricting capabilities
and skulls optimized for devouring large
prey
are enough to strike fear
and awe in anyone's heart
[Music]
you